[Música]
y
pareciera que la parte final del verano
ha traído todos los males al estado de
california en las últimas horas se
registró el valle de la muerte una
temperatura de 130 grados fahrenheit o
sea 54 grados centígrados la más alta
grabada en la historia de los eeuu
algunos expertos dijeron no estar muy
seguros de este registro lo que sí es un
hecho es que estas fuertes temperaturas
originaron tormentas de lluvia y
tormentas eléctricas en la mayor parte
del estado ocasionando estos rayos más
de 300 incendios incendios que han hecho
evacuar a miles de personas sobre todo
en el área del sur de san francisco en
el área de san jose y que tienen en
estado de emergencia al estado de
california y como si fuera poco para
acabar de completar se registró también
en las últimas horas un pequeño
terremoto de 4.3 en el mismo valle de la
muerte
[Música]
y de las temperaturas infernales de
california nos vamos al círculo polar
ártico donde el termómetro cada vez es
menos drástico esta región del mundo se
calienta dos veces más rápido que el
resto del planeta y groenlandia es el
mejor ejemplo de este fenómeno un
informe publicado recientemente asegura
que el hielo de los glaciares de la
mayor isla del mundo podría haberse
reducido al punto de no retorno es decir
que la nieve que cae cada año en este
territorio danés no es suficiente para
reponer el hielo que se derrite
anualmente en los meses de verano según
el estudio aunque seamos capaces de
reducir las emisiones que contribuyen al
calentamiento global el cielo seguirá
derritiéndose obviamente cuanto más
reduzcamos las emisiones más tardarán en
derretirse y más tiempo habrá de
adaptarse a las graves consecuencias si
todo el hielo de groenlandia se
derritiera el nivel del mar aumentaría
en 6 metros algo que haría desaparecer
muchas zonas costeras del mundo y esto
también está sucediendo en la punta sur
del planeta otro estudio demuestra que
la antártida ha perdido 4 billones de
toneladas de hielo
de 1994 esta pérdida es consecuencia
directa del aumento de la temperatura
del océano y podría hacer que el nivel
del mar se incremente otros 3 metros
algo que no va a suceder en dos o tres
años pero si en unas décadas un tiempo
futuro ahora pero que para las próximas
generaciones será su presente
[Música]